if you're not chasing perfection
and like
toys it's understood that you can go
cheaper which means in robot it's still
expensive but it's actually affordable
by a large number of people so it's a
really brilliant space to explore yeah
that's right it's uh and in fact we
realized pretty quickly that like
perfection is actually not fun yeah
because like in a traditional robotic
roboticist sense the first kind of path
planner and uh this is the you know the
part that i worked on out of the gate
was like a lot of the kind of ai systems
where you had these you know vehicles
and
you know cars racing kind of making
optimal maneuvers to try to kind of get
ahead and you realize very quickly that
like that's actually not fun because you
want the like chaos from mistakes and
the
and so you start to kind of
intentionally almost add noise to the
system uh in order to kind of create
more of a realism in the exact same way
the human player might start really
ineffective and inefficient and then
start to kind of increase their quality
bar as they
as they progress and there is a really
really aggressive constraint that's
forced on you by being a consumer
product where the price point matters a
ton particularly in like kind of an
entertainment where um
you know you you can't make a thousand
dollar product unless you're gonna meet
the like the expectations of a thousand
dollar product and so
um in order to make this work like your
cost of goods had to be like like you
know well under a hundred dollars uh uh
in the case of cosmo we got it under
fifty dollars end to end fully packaged
and delivered and it was under two
hundred dollars uh retail it cost the
retail yeah
so uh okay if we sit down like at this
early stages
if you go back to that
and you're sitting down and thinking
about what coswell looks like from a
design perspective and from a cost
perspective i imagine that was part of
the conversation
um
first of all what came first did you
have a cost in mind is there a target
you're trying to chase
did you have a vision in mind like size
that you have because there's a lot of
unique qualities to cosmos so for people
who don't know you should definitely
check it out is uh there's a display
there's eyes on the little display and
those eyes can
it's pretty low resolution eyes right
but they they still able to convey a lot
of emotion and there's this arm
like that out lift sort of lifts stuff
but there's something about arm movement
that adds even more kind of depth
it's like uh the face communicates
emotion and sadness and disappointment
and happiness and then the arms
kind of communicates i'm trying here
yeah i'm doing my best yeah
exactly so it's um
uh it's interesting because like um
all of cosmo is only four degrees of
freedom and two of them are the two
treads which is for basic movement and
so you literally have only
a head that goes up and down a lift that
goes up and down and then your two
wheels
and you have sound uh and a screen yeah
and a low resolution screen and with
that it's actually pretty incredible
what you can uh what you can come up
with where like you said it's a
it's a really interesting give and take
because there's a lot of ideas far
beyond that obviously as you can imagine
where like you said how big is it how
much degrees of freedom what does he
look like um uh what does he sound like
how does he communicate it's it's a
formula that actually scales way beyond
entertainment this is the formula for
human
kind of robot interface more generally
is you almost have this triangle between
um the physical aspects of it the
mechanics the industrial design what's
mass producible the cost constraints and
so forth
you have the ai side of
how do you understand the world around
you interact intelligently with it
execute what you want to execute so
perceive the environment
make intelligent decisions and
and move forward and then you have the
character side of it
most
companies have done anything in human
robot interaction really uh missed the
mark or under invest in the character
side of it um they over invest in the
mechanical side of it uh
you know and then varied results on the
ai side of it and so the thinking is
that you put more mechanical flexibility
into it you're gonna do better um you
don't necessarily you actually create a
much higher bar uh for a high roi
because now your price point goes up
your expectations go up and if the ai
can't meet it or the overall experience
isn't there you missed the mark
you